well Bernie Sanders just made one of the
most delusional statements that I think
anyone has ever made in history and I
don't think I'm over selling it too much
he was on Anderson Cooper last night and
and then this happened
you know how the president's gonna paint
you're talking democratic socialism
besides you know Venezuela is do enough
Americans know what you mean by that and
what that actually looks like well
Anderson that's why I'm on your show
tonight yeah that's right look what we
have to understand for example just for
example the United States is the only
major country on earth not to guarantee
health care to all people as a right in
many countries in Europe Germany for one
you go to college and the cost of
college is zero I think in Finland they
actually pay you to go to college in
most countries around the world the
level of income and wealth inequality
which in the United States today is
worse than at any time since the 1920s
with three families owning more wealth
than the bottom half of America that
level of income and wealth inequality is
much less severe than it is right here
in the United States no the taxes in
many of those countries are much higher
than they are into the individual
personal tax is much higher than they
are in the US but I suspect that a lot
of people in this country would be
delighted to pay more in taxes if they
had health if they had comprehensive
health care as a human right he says
people would be delighted delighted to
pay more in taxes no Bernie you see no
that's that's not the way it works
nobody wants to pay more in taxes nobody
does because if you know anyone can pay
more in taxes anyone can pay more if you
could send whatever amount you want to
the IRS on tax day well and any amount
as long as it's at least what you owe
oh and scare quotes there but beyond
that I mean if you want to ads you want
to send twenty percent more thirty
percent more than you owe you you're
free to do that they'll they'll
certainly take your money but so which
means that you you can
basically enact on your own any citizen
can enact a tax hike but it would just
be a personal tax hike that only you
would be subjected to
nobody does that why does anyone do that
because nobody wants to pay more in
taxes now I think this is where Bernie
gets confused because you see a lot of
people are delighted by tax increases
but they're delighted to have other
people pay more in taxes you see so yeah
leftists do advocate higher taxes and
they are delighted by higher taxes but
but only as long as those higher taxes
are imposed on other people not on them
personally on other people now me I
don't like to see anyone pay more in
taxes i I don't celebrate tax hikes on
anybody I'm in favor of tax cuts for
everybody because I just think that on
principle people should be able to keep
more of their own money and I also think
that the government has entirely too
much money with which to to waste
already but leftists do take a perverse
pleasure in tax hikes just as long as
the bill goes to someone else see that's
the way that this works that's that's a
fundamental misunderstanding it's every
single I mean without fail when you hear
someone advocating for higher taxes and
you sit down and you listen to them for
10 seconds you're gonna realize that oh
no honestly oh yeah they want me to pay
more not then that's what they're saying
what they're at what they're saying is
yes government go take from those people
over there not from me
very selfless very selfless indeed all
right now I want to I want to a lot I
want to talk about today including I
want to start by revisiting a
conversation from yesterday but first
before we get to that a word from Boland
branch you know we're never going to
agree on everything or maybe even on on
almost anything as a country but I think
we all can agree on on one thing which
is that we all can use a lot more sleep
getting great night's sleep is easier
than ever thanks to the world's softest
sheets
brought to you by bowline branch
everything ball and branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from 100%
pure organic cotton which means that
they're super soft and they get even
softer over time
everybody who tries Poland branch sheets
loves them and that's why they have
thousands of five-star reviews so you
just go listen to the people the people
have spoken and look at the reviews for
yourself
Forbes The Wall Street Journal Fast
Company they're all talking about Poland
branch these sheets have even been loved
by three US presidents and they want you
to love your purchase too so they offer
a no risk 30-day trial and free shipping
so you both of those things but you're
not gonna want to send them back you get
the trial you try them out you're gonna
want to keep them once you sleep on
their sheets you're never gonna want to
sleep on anything else so to get you
started right now my listeners get $50
off your first set of sheets at bowl and
branch calm promo code mats go to Boleyn
branch comm for $50 off your first set
of sheets that's B o ll and branch comm
promo code mat Bolin branch comm promo
code mint okay so as I said as I said at
the top there I want to revisit
something we talked about yesterday
briefly because I think that there's a
little bit more to be said about it we
discussed yesterday this new survey that
was conducted which shows that a
majority of mail managers are
uncomfortable working one-on-one with
female subordinates and see it CNBC
originally reported on this and they had
other stats as well senior level men say
that they're 12 times more likely to be
hesitant about one-on-one meetings with
a junior woman nine times more likely to
be hesitant to travel with a junior
woman they're more likely to be hesitant
to have a work dinner with a with a
junior woman rather than a you know a
subordinate man now as we talked about
yesterday this news has been met with
predictable finger wagging by the finger
wag is on the Left Sheryl Sandberg the
CEO of Facebook she says that it's
totally unacceptable for men to feel
uncomfortable work totally unacceptable
and of course the if men are
uncomfortable the real victims of that
discomfort are you guessed it women
Alexander
Cortese it was talking about this survey
and she said she decided that the men in
the survey they're just having a quote
hard time not being quote creepy that's
that's the way that she sums it up but I
was writing about this yesterday and I
found this article in the Chicago
Tribune written by a woman named Heidi
Stevens and her article is what makes me
bring this up again because she wrote
something that just completely proves
the point that she was trying to
disprove it really is amazing so she
wrote this thing which which offers some
dismissive and sarcastic pointers for
men in the workplace now it's sort of
hard to take these pointers seriously
because she admits outright that she
doesn't understand the issue
she says I'm confused about the root of
these male managers discomfort do they
not know how to interact with women in a
way that doesn't accidentally or overtly
imply they'd like to sleep with them or
do they worry that me too has women
going around willy-nilly making up
stories of harassment and assaults that
didn't happen and they can't risk being
the subject of such stories well yeah
kind of I mean that is sort of what's
happening but she says that to be
interval I don't really understand it so
she doesn't understand but despite her
professed ignorant she plugs right along
with some helpful pieces of advice this
is what she says with some advice for
everybody
don't pleasure yourself in two potted
plants as Harvey Weinstein is alleged to
have done don't have a secret button
that locks your office door behind
people as Matt Lauer is alleged bludge
to have done don't send a bunch of gross
inappropriate text to a direct report as
Kevin Quinn a former staffer for House
Speaker Michael Madigan is alleged to
have done these are her pieces of advice
so don't fornicate with the flora don't
have secret locking mechanisms installed
in your office easy enough you know by
the latest count only like two or three
men in the country have done either of
those things so it's you know sort of
easy for the rest of us not to do that
but here's where and she's not done
doling out advice here's where she
undercuts her whole case she says I just
is so interesting because it it it
encapsulates the whole problem
inadvertently she says treat your female
colleagues and subordinates the way
you'd want to be treated by a male in
power would you want him to tell you how
nice you look in that suit with now
again this is talking to men okay would
you want him to tell you how nice you
look in that suit would you want him to
ask you if you're happy in your
relationship would you want him to rest
his hand lightly on your shoulder when
he talks talk to your female colleagues
and subordinates about the same topics
you talk to your male colleagues and
subordinates about the NBA Finals their
kids summer dates summer break plans the
china tariffs the weather your book club
why the breakroom coffee is so bad the
profit and loss report that's due later
that day okay so that's her advice now
actually I have been told by men that I
look good in my suit that I'm wearing
and I have myself dispensed similar
compliments to men um there's nothing
strange or inappropriate about that it's
a compliment
so she says what you would never want a
man to compliment your outfit well sure
I would why not if I'm wearing a great
suit and a guy say hey man nice suit
looks great I'm sure that that's that's
I would be happy with that why wouldn't
I be
do you not think that men complement
each other it's it's a really norm see
this is someone who clearly just never
just doesn't know anything about men and
that's the that's what you find with
feminists is that they just know they
and now they make this claim about men
in regards to women they said although
you're if you're especially if you're a
male conservative you don't know
anything about women now it's actually
the reverse is true you you clearly know
nothing about men it uses nothing at all
that you think we would what we would
call and har did you just compliment my
suit how dare you well I never um no no
man would react them you know what if
another man says hey great sir you look
great
I would say oh cool thanks that would be
it and then I would move on I would
never think about it again I would just
move on with my life
what I want a guy asking me how my
marriage is going well sure why not you
know what I meet up with a guy friend I
will definitely say to them hey how are
things going at home how's the wife it's
a normal thing to say it's just it's
completely normal or if they're dating
someone they're not married then you can
be a little bit more specific about the
asking about the relationship like hey
are you still with that girl how's that
going it's normal that's a normal thing
to talk about and so how would I feel if
a man said that to me I would feel
perfectly fine with it I would say Oh
things are going great you know the wife
is doing well and that's it what I want
a guy resting his hand on my shoulder no
I mean not particularly I wouldn't but I
wouldn't report it to HR either now I
prefer to avoid physical contact with
everybody with the exception of my wife
and my kids like I they're the only ones
who I'm okay with invading my personal
space everybody else I what I would like
what I would prefer is if everybody
respected a thirty foot radius of
personal space for me at all times
that's what I would just personally I
would like that but but I cannot say
that I'm sexually harassed just because
people don't know that I have those
personal space demands and therefore
don't respect them because they
understand that they are a little bit
unreasonable it's just personally that's
what I would like and some people are
more physical you know than others maybe
not joe biden levels of physical but but
some people are just are more like that
I've got friends that are more like you
know patch on the back and that kind of
some people are like that men and women
we've all had conversation go out to a
speaking event or something and I'll be
meeting people afterwards and you always
have these older women you know women
are probably in their 70s who will come
up and they'll they'll grab your hand
and they'll just hold it's like 10
minutes while they're talking and kind
of like lightly shaking it while they
talk to you and for like 10 minutes
they're holding your hand now am i a big
fan of that not really but but
I mean they're being friendly and it's
kind of funny you know it's just they're
they're just sweet old ladies and this
is what they do it's not a big deal
right and there are some older men who
are like that as well so how would I so
would I consider that would I be
scandalized by that would I no no I
wouldn't and this is the point she says
she says though you would never treat
guys like that yes I would and then she
proceeds to tell us to treat women like
we would treat guys yeah but as I just
explained I would treat guys the way
that you claim we only treat women but
you say don't treat women like that so
you see the confusion here it it just
doesn't work because the two mixes mixed
messages going on here I would
compliment a man on his outfit if it's a
nice out that he looks good in it you're
saying don't say that to women so we
should treat women differently is what
you're saying now it's recommended that
we talk about the NBA Finals instead but
wait a second according to a BBC article
that I just pulled up sports lingo at
work is quote hidden sexism that quote
reinforces the idea that work the
workplace is or should be a man cave
with water coolers so now I imagine that
the same could be claimed about any
attempt to talk politics or about the
Chinese tariffs or whatever on the job
talk about their kids summer Blake break
plans she she recommends or book clubs
well then won't I be guilty of
stereotypically assuming that the woman
that I'm talking to has kids and is
interested in book clubs isn't that a
stereotype see again this is exactly the
point this is why what men are
uncomfortable talking to women at work
and this is why feminism has hurt women
by just by yes making it more difficult
for them on the job because men are just
freaked out now and and they're not
freaked out around men but they are a
little bit around women because of this
kind of stuff the rules change from
moment to moment and person to person
anything can be sexist anything can be
stru construed as harassment maybe your
female worker is like Heidi Stevens and
would like to talk about the NBA Finals
but maybe she's more inclined to see
talk of sports at the workplace
as sexism that reinforces a male centric
environment we have no way of knowing it
could go either way that's that's the
kind of conversation that if you I could
talk I could bring that up to a man it's
no problem enough to worry about
anything right more than more than
likely he'll want to engage in that
conversation maybe he's not interested
in it and then find whatever you move on
you talk about something else
but you bring it up to a woman and
there's a chance that she'll think that
it's sexist because there have been
articles written explaining why it's
sexist we have no way knowing and it's
clear that the woman isn't necessarily
going to speak up okay so she may suffer
through the sexist conversational
assault silently seething about it
because we failed to read her mind and
then later on use the incident to get us
fired or worse that's the way it could
go it's not gonna go that way with a man
we know that which means we're probably
gonna be more inclined to just bring
that conversation up to a man here's the
other thing about men that you need to
understand I think well just like any
other like like humans in general we
don't like to risk our jobs we don't
like to risk false accusations we also
just you know we're not a big fan of
games and BS we just we just want to be
bothered with stuff like that so yeah
we're kind of just like it's very
practical minded so we're thinking like
okay I want to talk about sports at work
so why am I gonna bother when it's this
whole minefield I don't even why am I
gonna bother even trying to navigate
that there's no point I'll just go talk
to a guy about it or I will talk about
it at all
the me2 movement and feminism in general
have made a few things clear number one
literally anything can be sexist it all
depends on the feelings of the woman
number two women are not expected to
speak up and let you know that they're
uncomfortable in my opinion they should
be expected to do that just like any
person should be if you're uncomfortable
say something as an adult as a grown-up
it's your responsibility to say
something I mean it's like you hear
these stories about louis c.k and how he
you know I mean disgusting how we
pleasured himself in front of women
well now of course obviously doing that
on the job is completely inappropriate
or doing that at any anywhere in any
context is completely inappropriate and
disgusting and wrong and creepy and
perverse and degenerate but when it
comes to speaking up you know in every
case apparently he would ask these women
hey do you mind if I and they would just
say oh sure
meanwhile in their head they're
uncomfortable but it's like well of
course you're uncovering say you're not
don't don't say yes what you don't mean
it
just just save leave right but say
something and leave if you're
uncomfortable I think we can expect
people to do that we all man a man or
woman we all have to do that and that's
especially the case you know you take
something that's a lot less severe and
gross than that just take a conversation
let's say that's making you
uncomfortable well then definitely in
that case if you're uncomfortable with
the [ __ ] leave the room you know that you
could just say nothing and leave that's
an option or speak up and say you know I
don't think we should be talking about
this I think we can expect everyone man
or woman to speak up to be adults to
take charge of the situation to make
your own thoughts known because you
can't expect anyone to read your mind
but that's how we know from the me2
movement that you know we can't expect
that and and and then number three we
know believe women so the women's
version of events will be believed must
be believed and the only thing the male
offender is allowed to do is grovel and
apologize so is it really so surprising
that men in this environment with the
rules set up the way they are may be
wary about interacting with women
especially when nobody else is present
to witness it
so perhaps you know we should stop and
think about that and think about the
damage that it's doing not just to men
but to women as well because there are a
lot of
of normal non feminist non crazy women
out there who are not looking to entrap
men or trick men or you know get men
into trouble make things up who are the
kinds of people who won't be offended by
a conversation about sports or whatever
even if they're not interested in it who
won't be offended if you complement them
there are plenty of women like that
plenty the majority you know are like
that but because of crazy feminists you
know men don't know necessarily they
know a woman well already they don't
know if they don't know where the woman
falls on that spectrum and so
unfortunately a lot of women get lumped
in with that just as a precautionary
measure men are gonna say well she might
not be a crazy feminist but I don't know
so I I guess I just have to act as
though she is just for my own
self-preservation and that's not fair to
those women but whose fault is it it's
the fault of the crazy feminists it's
not the fault of the men because the men
are just again there it's just
self-preservation they're just they've
got it you've got to be prudent it's not
worth risking your job your livelihood
your life over all right so I thought
that was a interesting staying in the
vein of feminism for a minute the
women's u.s. soccer team beat the thirty
fourth ranked island team a couple days
ago by thirteen and nothing and Kristen
is a couple things that stemmed from
this victory that are sort of annoying
and stupid
first of all Kristen Gillibrand had this
to say on a tweet she says here's an
idea if you win 13 to nothing the most
goals for a single game in World Cup
history you should be paid at least
equally to the men's team now she's not
the only one to say this of course I've
heard this elsewhere the women's soccer
team is running roughshod over low
ranked opponents and this prove that
they should be paid the same as the
men's team because they're just as good
I guess and they are great athletes and
there's no question that they're better
at soccer than me
if it was me and and you know and guys
like me versus the Women's World Cup
team I have no doubt that they would win
handily against us but that's because I
don't play soccer because I prefer to
play sports personally but any case yes
they would beat me I'll admit that but
the same time I can't help but note that
this women's team did lose a couple
years ago to a team of under 15 high
school boys in a scrimmage it's not
funny I I'm sorry I don't mean to laugh
they did lose to two teenage boys in a
scrimmage yeah that's true you could
look that up Google that one that did
happen my only point bringing that up
okay is it's no disrespect it's just a
point out for all the people that are
you know talking now but there's a pay
disparity and why aren't they paid the
same you see how good they are you know
I I'm just trying to point out the vast
Gulf that separates male athletes from
female athletes I mean it's just they're
like in two different universes I mean
and that's why male athletes generally
get paid more and that's why there's
generally more interest in men's sports
because the athletes are just a lot
better and they're just in they're more
fun to watch now not in every sport
something like gymnastics for instance
you know I think it's because the just
the physiology of men versus women
I think women can oftentimes be more
gifted in in that area more graceful and
everything but in these other kind of
sports especially these team sort of
sports it's different the men are just a
lot more fun to watch because they're
just so much better and and that's fine
men are allowed to be better than women
it's okay to acknowledge that it's okay
to acknowledge it because it's true why
is it that the NBA gets great ratings
while nobody watches the dumb you in the
WNBA I don't this is a WNBA even still
on I don't even know well it's because
NBA athletes are some of the best
athletes in the world
they are so
ridiculously good and it's amazing to
watch what they can do on the court and
that's why people watch the NBA a WNBA
team on the other hand would easily lose
to an above average high school boys
team and probably any would even be
close
just like the soccer players just like
with a soccer situation that again is
how vast the divide is between the two
skill levels and that's fine it's
nothing to panic over men are men and
women are women and there's no sexism in
that there's also no sexism in the
criticisms that the women's team has
faced for excessive celebrating okay
while the women's team was trouncing the
34th rally there was a thirty fourth
ranked island team and they built an
insurmountable lead they still
celebrated every goal like it was the
game-winner and they were running around
the field and pumping their fists and
and doing all this stuff and some people
have argued that it was poor
sportsmanship on their part you know to
me to be gloating over your tenth goal
in a soccer match it is match soccer
match right not soccer game I don't know
is this the soccer sporting competition
to be gloating over it is you know it's
just it's not good sportsmanship it's so
it's kind of lame and it just it makes
you look a bush-league look it makes it
look like amateur hour really and that's
the criticism anyway that some people
have have articulated here's a here's a
just that just kind of explained it
here's a CBS report that summarizes the
controversy the u.s. women's blowout win
yesterday at the world cup did not come
without controversy some are saying they
showed poor sportsmanship by celebrating
after every one of their 13 goals Roxana
Saberi reports from Paris as Team USA's
players piled on goal
after goal last night it's loose setting
a World Cup record their parents being
[Music]
[Applause]
their fans cheered and Thailand wept
stirring the sympathy of spectators like
Kaylie Ferrera a Phoenix did you guys
feel bad for the Thai at least a little
bit yeah because it was a really bad
loss for them so bad US coach Jill Ellis
had to field questions about whether the
best team in the world should have gone
easier on a team ranked 34th I sit here
and I go if this is ten nil and amends
well a couple we get in the same
questions to be quite honest it's 13
goals that sparked much more criticism
even former teammate hopes solo called
some of the celebrations a little
overboard
co-captain Megan Rapinoe defended her
team they can come at us cuz I think our
only crime was an explosion of joy last
night some US players say what last
night's game really showed is that other
countries need to invest more in women's
soccer and they urged players like
Thailand's Miranda Mills
not to feel defeated I told her that
it's a dream of all of ours to play in
the World Cup and to stay encouraged
Team USA's next game is on Sunday
against Chile which is ranked 39th in
the world Roxana Saberi
CBS News Paris so you heard what I think
was the head coach said there's I well
the men's team wouldn't be criticized
like this and this is something that's
been echoed by the media the soccer team
was criticized both for running up the
score and trying aggressively to score
more goals even when there were only a
few minutes left and then and then also
they celebrating so much but it's it's
we're told that that's it's sexist
account to criticize them for that these
are sexist criticisms because men are
never criticized that way as the story
goes Casey hunt an NBC reporter sent out
a tweet said don't celebrate too much
Bros said no one ever and then a bunch
of think think pieces have been written
about this issue about the sexism of
criticizing female athletes including
this one from PopSugar which is of
course a great great
location any publication called PopSugar
you know you're gonna find great content
very very intelligent content they have
an article titled why criticism of the
u.s. women's soccer team is sexist so
very straightforward I appreciate that
and then the article says in part the
women's soccer team in a thrilling first
game of the 2019 Women's World Cup won
with a record-breaking 13 to 0 score
first of all that's not a thrilling
games weight a thrilling game they won
13 to nothing it's not thrilling that's
the opposite of thrilling that's that's
a blowout and you know it's I mean it's
thrilling if you're a fan of the team I
guess but it's not really a thrilling
game in general search but she says but
unsurprising in the context of heedless
sexist double standards in the world of
sports the players were almost
immediately criticized for their
resoundingly shortly after the game
predominantly male commentators and
Twitter users questioned why the won yes
I'm sure they went through and they
looked at all the criticisms on Twitter
and they counted them all by sex and
discovered that it was predominantly
male right okay
predominantly male commentators and
Twitter users questioned why the team
ran up the score to 13 to zero despite
the fact that in the event of a tie
during the world turned to group stage
of the World Cup the team with the
highest goal differential would advance
to the knockout round the players were
also criticized for continuing to
celebrate their goals throughout those
90 minutes to play suggesting this
reflected poor sportsmanship in contrast
similar criticisms have yet to be lodged
against men's athletic teams for
ruthless high-margin victories and
repeated celebrations the 1992 u.s.
men's basketball team defeated opponents
by an average of 44 points during the
Olympic Games and is still
affectionately known as the dream team
the annual NFL the annual NFL honors
ceremony includes a category four
celebration of the year there's a
gendered backlash against the women's
team is even more frustrating and
notable considering the players having a
gob of above above the bloke I can't
even tell you something I'm gonna throw
up if I keep reading that this of course
is just grade-a pure unadulterated
nonsense
it is completely untrue completely false
totally completely utterly ridiculous it
shows yet again the theme of the show
how feminists don't understand men know
nothing about men at all know nothing
about men's sports have no idea what
they're talking about on any subject
male athletes are criticized all the
time for excessive celebration and for
running up the score and all that the
dream team was criticized for running up
the score
they're called the dream team because
they were so insanely talented these
were some of the best basketball players
that had ever lived on the planet that
were on one team that's why they were
the dream team now the u.s. women's
soccer team that I know these are very
good athletes the this is not a
collection of the best soccer players
ever to live so that's why they're not
the dream team
okay a collection of the best soccer
players ever to live will be all men's
players that's how you know that that's
that this isn't the dream team now this
was that these were the best basketball
players ever us you know some of them
and that's why they were called the
dream team but they were yeah they score
by the average of 44 to 44 points or
whatever they were criticized for that
they were the to set the 2007 Patriots
who went undefeated but finally lost in
the Superbowl and were beating teams by
like 55 to 3 of these crazy scorers
running up the score they were
criticized for that constant it was it
was a never ending topic of conversation
in 2007 about how the Patriots are bad
sportsmen and running up the scores just
convinced it was an ongoing debate on
ESPN and among football fans and
commentators in fact as for celebrating
you know up until recently you weren't
allowed to celebrate at all in the NFL
and now they do allow some celebration
but I think you can still be penalized
for you could be fined for it if you go
to four there are certain things you're
not allowed to do in the course of a
celebration one of the oldest cliches in
sports is act like you've been there
before and when you're that's just it's
something that you hear if you watch men
playing in the NFL if you watch men
playing in the NBA if you watch men
playing in the MLB you're gonna hear
this cliche act like you've been there
before and what that's always targeted
at a man who's you know you know made a
basket scored a touchdown got a home run
and then freaks out about it it acts
like it's the first time he's ever
scored a point in his career as a
professional athlete then people will
say act like you've been there buddy be
professional you know at the the cool
thing is to act like you've done it a
million times and it's no big deal
right you score the touchdown just like
casually hand the ball to the ref and
then walk off the field now that's
badass
that that's a Power Move right there so
this is a constant conversation so when
women are criticized for it they are
being treated exactly like the men
exactly like they say they want to be
treated but yet again what we find is
that when women are treated like men
feminists complain and when they're not
treated like men feminists complain it's
so it's it's bogus and you know what yes
it is lame to go running I mean you saw
some of that stuff to go running
frantically around the field pumping
your fists and gloating after you scored
the 10th time against a team that isn't
even ranked in the top 30
yeah that's it's lame it's kind of
stupid it makes you look it makes you
look like an amateur it just does if Tom
Brady ran around the field screaming
triumphantly after scoring his sixth
touchdown against the Buffalo Bills to
go up 53 to 7 you're damn right people
would criticize him for that they would
say you're Tom Brady what do you freak
out about this anyway you scored a you
gotta throw a touchdown against the bill
you're freaking out come on but he does
do stuff like that and he has and he is
criticized for it all the time it's one
of the main things Tom Brady's
criticized for act like you've been
there before
be professional be cool it's it's a it's
a normal thing in the NFL if you're up
you know if you're up by two or more
scores and you have the ball with two or
three minutes left in the game and the
other team doesn't have any timeouts
it's customary to take a knee and not
even try to run a play and just run and
just let the let the game end that's
what you're kind of supposed to do by
the customs of the game if you're in
that situation as the winning team and
you take shots at the end you start
throwing air palmares to the end zone
yes you're gonna be criticized for that
severely because people are going to
you're just you're trying to pad your
stats against the team that it is you
already beat essentially so but now my
own personal opinion is that you know I
I generally don't mind the celebrations
I think if people get pumped up in
sports and they get excited and that's
great it is a game you're supposed to
have fun in the NFL I like some of the
more creative touchdown celebrations you
see them do now I think it's just it's
it's a cuz it's a game at the end of the
day it's still a game so that's fine but
it can get to a point where it's
overboard and if you're if you're
decimating a team especially if you're
decimating a team that you're supposed
to beat if it's a team that you're
decimating that you're supposed to
decimate yeah then celibate an overly
celebrating just makes you look foolish
in my opinion now if you're doing it for
the underdog doing that to the team that
was supposed to beat you and maybe maybe
there's more of a reason there but as
the favorite I would I would agree with
the criticism but there's nothing
gendered about it alright let's go to
two emails Matt wall show at gmail.com
Matt wall show at gmail.com this one is
from Victoria says hi Matt my name is
Victoria big fan of the show last year a
film called boy erased released which is
a biography about a young man who went
to a Baptist gay conversion camp this
film was adapted by a fort from a memoir
has won many accolades I was raised
Christian and have been a Christian for
most of my life I've never even heard of
this sort of thing I was wondering if
you have and what are your opinions of
them and are they common somewhere in
the u.s. they seem creepy and just wrong
to me if they do indeed still exist keep
up the great work
hi Victoria I've only ever heard of the
gay conversion camps and gay conversion
therapy all that stuff I've only ever
heard about that from people railing
against it like you I have never heard
of I had never heard of such a thing
until the left started fear-mongering
about it I'm not saying it doesn't exist
or it didn't exist at some point but
it's certainly not nearly as widespread
as its presented and not nearly
widespread enough to justify all the
panicking that people do about it you
know the other thing about this gay
conversion stuff is that I think
sometimes sometimes you'll have totally
normal Christian counseling that maybe
can be rebranded with that nefarious
sounding label so as far as actual camps
where gay kids are sent against the will
is creepy kind of reprogramming that
goes on and you know electroshock
therapy all that kind of stuff again I'm
not saying that stuff didn't happen in
the past but I've in current day America
I've never heard that I been a Christian
for 32 years I've never heard of it
never encountered it just never but I
think you could have for instance a
person who's struggling with homosexual
thoughts or urges doesn't want those
thoughts and seeks counseling from a
pastor or a Christian counselor because
they don't want those feelings and then
they receive counseling and then I guess
probably that's going to be labeled gay
conversion therapy but it's not as
though this was a gay person abducted
off the street and brought in a bus to a
camp somewhere okay
this is someone who sought counseling
and received it totally of their own
volition so if that's what gay
conversion is then if it's that meaning
just someone who goes and seeks
counseling of their own free will and
volition because they're struggling with
something but they don't want to
struggle with if that's what we call gay
conversion therapy then I don't see a
problem with it but I think to label it
that way is disingenuous the stuff that
you're talking about yeah it I don't
think that that's a widespread
phenomenon I'll put it that way all
right this is from Don says man I myself
I'm not a huge fan of parades I agree
that it's a glorified traffic jam but I
think you neglected a major issue with
your
own personal faith the Pope every time
he goes out in public is basically
parading around Catholicism and tract
you may even call it a celibacy Parade
thousands flock the streets causing
major traffic delays for miles around I
demand you recant your parade hypocrisy
I think a celibacy parade actually may
be a great idea maybe that's the way to
counteract all this all these other
sexually oriented parades you find out
there but I won't recant Don because
actually I you know I know you're half
kidding but I'm not a big fan of the
kind of hysteria and and pageantry that
surrounds the Pope I'm a Catholic but I
don't worship the Pope no Catholic does
okay let's be clear about that no
Catholic worship suppose he's just a man
he's not God we all know that yet
sometimes the pageantry around him the
way we treat the papacy can give the
wrong impression
and I think Catholics Catholics need to
acknowledge that and understand that it
does sometimes come off the wrong way
and sometimes it can approach something
like worship but in the same sense that
we might talk about celebrity worship so
that's the kind of worship that we're
talking about someone who freaks out
because they see I don't know Lady Gaga
you know walk it down the street
okay well that person isn't literally
worshiping Lady Gaga as a God this isn't
someone who actually thinks that Lady
Gaga has supernatural capabilities but
they treat her as something other than
just another human and they keep way too
much agile a ssin and admiration upon
her personally just because they like
her you know her songs and and and
they're impressed with her celebrity so
with the Pope I think you can find
something like that sometimes with some
people just as with the president there
can be something like that and I'm not a
fan of it in those cases either I'm not
a fan of it in any case and I think with
the Pope in particular
I think it could be a good thing maybe
to maybe to pull back on some of that
some of that pageantry all right this is
let's see do we have another one
I thought we don't know okay well this
one is from Nick another Catholic
question says I'm Catholic I was
recently reading about several miracles
including the Shroud of Turin the tilma
of Our Lady of Guadalupe I understand
that the church runs miraculous claims
through the gauntlet to ensure their
validity many scientists and experts who
are atheists are tasked with finding
natural explanations for the events in
question if there's any doubt the church
dismisses the claim what are your
thoughts on these and other miracles do
you believe in them what role if any do
you think they should play in our faith
and do you think they can be used as a
means of evangelization while they are
by no means the basis of my faith I do
sometimes fall back on them when I begin
to doubt the existence of God I really
appreciate you getting to my question
hope your leg is getting better by the
day Nick I treat miracle claims on a
case-by-case basis i which i think is
what we all should do you know you look
into them personally decide if you are
inclined to believe that they're
supernatural or not I think that's what
we all should do we shouldn't believe a
miracle claim just because someone
claims it obviously if we did that then
we'd have to believe every single
miracle claim that anyone ever makes and
not just miracle and we'd have to
believe everything everyone tells us and
we would clearly we don't do that so the
fact that someone said something is not
enough reason to believe that it's true
most of the time especially when it's
something like a miracle now if your
wife walks into the room and says hey
it's raining outside well okay well that
the fact that your wife said it's
raining is probably enough reason to
believe that it's raining because
raining raining rain is something that
happens on a daily basis it's completely
normal
you trust your wife you know her there's
no conceivable reason why she'd lie
about it so yeah you'll just take that
on faith as it were but a miracle claim
you know someone you don't even know
says oh you know Jesus appeared to me or
oh this or that happened well we know
that those are not daily occur
we don't know anything about this person
personally so we don't know about their
trustworthiness and we know that these
are the kinds of stories that people are
willing to make up and there are plenty
of reasons why a person might make them
up so with all that in mind then we I
think we have to look specifically at it
look at the evidence and draw our
conclusions from there so a couple
examples you you get I'm inclined to
believe the Shroud of Turin as being
authentic because it's been subjected to
numerous scientific studies through the
years its its validity has not been
disproven and I know that failure to
disprove something is not the same thing
as proving the affirmative of that thing
but the fact that the Shroud is
basically a photographic negative of you
know in the image of a man who's
suspiciously wounded just like Jesus was
wounded as is told in the Gospels and
and that still nobody has been able to
explain how a thousand years ago or even
five hundred years ago someone could
have produced an image like this well
that kind of cinches it for me so yeah I
believe it I believe the shroud and
there probably is an element of just
sort of intuition with some of these
things because I think there's a lot of
evidence but I also just I think beyond
that I just say you know I guess we
might say it's the it's the Holy Spirit
as well guiding us on that as for Our
Lady of Guadalupe the tilma I am
skeptical there for those who aren't
familiar with that story as the story
goes Mary the Blessed Mother appeared to
a guy named Juan Diego in the 15th
century in Mexico and there's a whole
story there that I'm not gonna get into
it cuz I don't have time but there's now
a cloak essentially with an image of
Christ's mother and supposedly it
appeared miraculously okay that's the
really bare-bones story there but I'm
skeptical because I can see the image
right you know you can go you could look
at the
go online look it up the tilma and
you'll see it and when you look at the
image it looks like a painting
it doesn't look miraculous at all in my
opinion it just looks like something
that someone could have pay it looks
like something that almost anyone could
have painted and I don't see why a
miraculous image would look like a
rather basic painting right like if God
is it if through super if if through
divine intervention an image is going to
appear on a surface somewhere why would
it look like a painting you know the the
Shroud of Turin does not look like a
painting that's the if the Shroud of
Turin just look like a painting then I
would say it's probably a painting but
it doesn't it looks like a photograph of
someone and so that's what makes you
stop and go how does that get there it
doesn't look like some something someone
want to paint it especially not you know
centuries ago but what the tell me you
look at it and there's if no one told
you the whole story behind it you would
look at it and say okay someone painted
that so you know I just I don't see any
compelling reason to believe that it's
more than a painting other than the fact
that I would like to believe that it's
more than a painting but the fact that I
would like to believe it isn't a reason
at all so that's that's how I would
parse I could be wrong about one or both
of them who knows you know I don't know
just these are my own opinions but I
tend with any miracle claim I think my
first reaction is skepticism in that ok
well that's that's incredible stories of
literally incredible and oftentimes
incredible stories aren't true but I'm
all ears I'm not going to rule it out
obviously we can't rule out the
miraculous so bring me the evidence and
I'll look at it and if I see compelling
evidence I'll probably believe it with
the tale my just haven't I haven't seen
compelling evidence other other than
just a lot of people through the
centuries have believed it but that's
that's not evidence of anything people
wrong things all the time especially if
they want to believe it because it's a
beautiful story and it is by the way all
right we will leave it there thanks
everybody for watching thanks for
listening
Godspeed today on the Ben Shapiro show
and Ron draws everybody closer to war
that's today on the Ben Shapiro show